الفرقه التطوعيه انشات عدد كبير من النقاط
الايواء المؤقت في محيط مدينه جنديرس
بالتنسيق مع المجلس المحلي والمنظمات
الانسانيه بالاضافه الى ان في المدن
الاخرى كمدينه اعزاز هنا التي نقف فيها
انشا عدد من المتطوعين نقاط ايواء مؤقته
للاهالي كمان شاهد هذه هنا خلفيه هذه
الخيمتان هنا تاوي حوالي 150 عائله هذه
الخيام التي ينام فيها النساء والاطفال
بينما الرجال يجد ان يجلسون هنا منذ ساعات
الليل طوال ساعات الليل رغم شده البرد نحن
نرتجف من شده البرد البرد الذي تتصل درجات
الحراره الى دون الصفر يحاولون الحصول على
الدفء باحراق بعض الاطارات او بهذه
الاغذيه بعضهم ينام في هذه السيارات رغم
انها شديده البروده ايضا ينامون داخل هذه
السيارات او خلف هذه السيارات ولكن الواقع
صعب جدا المنظمات الانسانيه لا تقدم الا
ما تستطيع عليه تقديمه بعض المواد
الغذائيه او بعض الاغطيه او حتى بعض
المدافئ ولكن هناك نقص كبير في حليب على
اطفال والمواد الاساسيه لهؤلاء الاطفال
الفرق الانسانيه جمعت بعض الاغطيه من
المتبرعات الاهالي وجلبتها لهؤلاء الذين
لا يعلمون مصيرهم والى اين تحل بهم الحال
هل هي ان سيعودون الى منازل او الى خيام
لتبدا مرحله معاناه جديده وفصل معاناه
جديد في حياتهم